this is going to be my last video
addressing and updating what's been
going on with toei animation i say that
not because i've heard anything from
them or youtube because i haven't it's
not because i haven't felt an enormous
amount of support from so many people
because i have it's actually for an
entirely different reason i never
thought would be a factor and that's me
whenever i would work on a video in the
past no matter how long it was or how
tired i got while working on it i never
felt comfortable settling for anything
less than what i thought was the very
best i could do and over the years i've
grown accustomed to pushing myself to
work harder longer and all that comes
with that mindset regardless of how i
felt physically which is a big reason as
to why those videos i lost meant so much
to me but today i think i've reached my
limit to be clear i would never consider
myself someone that suffered from any
form of anxiety i'm very fortunate in
that regard but over the last week i've
not been able to sleep and due to the
anxiety associated with this occasion
and the scope of it i've also had
trouble eating this is an entirely new
experience for me and one that has been
fueled by what's been going on both
publicly and privately in my personal
life to say that a lot of things went
wrong this week would be an
understatement and how this has impacted
me and made me feel has been something i
never expected the difference in how i
was feeling in the first video and the
second video was enormous and today it's
even worse
in those videos i tried to be as honest
and transparent about how i was feeling
and the details that were unfolding
around me i chose to make this public
because i wanted not to lose three years
worth of work for what i consider to be
unfair reasons but i don't think that
this is something that can change at
least not now i hope it does in the
future but right now i need this to be
over
i no longer stand by a boycott of toy
animation and in our first step in
moving away from this horrible week the
two videos i've made addressing this
situation will be unlisted and a new
video will be released tomorrow it's the
first half of my review for the amazing
spider-man with andrew garfield the
portion of that video that i will upload
tomorrow was written recorded and edited
before this whole thing happened and
unfortunately i wasn't able to finish it
this will also be my last video of 2021
and over the next few weeks leading into
2022 i need to sit back and reassess
with my team how we're feeling and what
our plans will be for the future of this
channel to those of you that wanted me
to keep pushing this cause i'm sorry
that i can't keep going and to those
that found my actions disrespectful know
that this was never my intention i was
just trying to stand up for what i
thought i should either way this entire
week hasn't been fruitless thanks to you
and the love that you've shared with
both myself and my team over the last
week 10 000 united states dollars will
be donated to the light ring charity
which supports suicide prevention for
the youth of japan and honestly that's
what i'm going to be focusing on after
all of this the generosity of all of you
to help myself my team and the children
of japan this christmas
so thank you have a happy holiday and
i'll see you all next year